well state health officials say this  week would mark two weeks from new  year's celebrations  and that is obviously a big concern  moving forward cases have continued to  go up throughout the holiday season  however rural health departments say  they have not noticed a change  this week will be critical for hospitals  health officials are asking people  to take precautions and get tested we'll  see it over the next few days  if you feel that you did participate in  an event that could have exposed you to  covid specifically you are in close  proximity of other people  unmasked it's really important that you  get tested